gilli you've been playing red day I have
listened one word what it's a grind it's
not only a grind um here's the thing
about video games is that when you play
a video game you still want it to feel
like a video game but they made it so
real the way he moves the way he walks
if he grabs and bow and arrow from his
saddle
it just takes 40 seconds yeah that's
realistic it's realistic then you got a
you know you're with a group of people
you have kids in your you know in your
camp what's the story about
it's basically you're following a gang
you're in a gang but I'm going to talk
about this gang in a second okay so you
have to you know you have to contribute
to the gang GIDA bring over deer meat
and kill you honey
yeah your favorite here's the number one
thing is is that this isn't the late
eighteen 1800s and I wanted to be
historically accurate
everything else is accurate except for
the gang the gangs not there's three
black guys in the gang and a full-blown
Mexican and then half American Indian
half black guy yeah okay the Mexican guy
right like he's just it's it's like you
you're not at work back in the day you
weren't able to walk into a bar with
just four black guys you know a man in
the eighty nine where are like the
Chinese people during that time period
eight well we were there we were
building the railroad railroad and we
had also opium dens a single we've never
seen a single Chinese so far no another
thing about my Asians in there too but
the game though when you walk into a
town it's living and breathing I mean I
walk a good their graphics I mean it's
not even just good it's like I walked to
a it was a store you know like a general
store and there was like five guys just
one guy leaning against a wall some guys
sitting on a thing you know and it just
it looked so real the way he opens the
door it's not like he just opens it like
you would open a door yeah like it's
everything is so real
how are the weapons and the mods and the
Steve
I would have [ __ ] get to it man yeah
sorry Jesus
another good thing about the game is is
that the weather system oh yeah the wind
the way the trees sweat you could just
feel it you know it's just gorgeous and
it's one of those things where if you're
a game or you just have to play it
mm-hmm it's just they spent what five
years on it would be more than that
honestly yeah I mean it you can it's on
the screen everything about it the
detail I mean it you I don't know how
anything works did the little symbols on
the bottom don't really teach you they
don't teach you an are and you have to
figure it out real life like real life I
mean there's one guy there wasn't one
poor guy and murdered around by a river
with the bone air with the bone area and
its open world like that yeah
accidentally did he was like hey buddy
come here I want to show you something
and you should killed him and I had my
bow and arrow and and if you plus left
trigger if you don't have a thing you
can start a dialogue but I had a weapon
so I press left trigger and I go like
this right and it was anybody and he
shot me right and then I put my bullet
right through his neck he dies and all
this little symbol says that you know I
mean that because he I guess karma yeah
that's in there yeah that's it I think
it's like Westworld you're the bad guy
are they
it really there are animals you can have
oh my god it's not only that the way
they die the animals it's really so it
takes forever they you know me they
stumble for a while right they fall and
they're still breathing putting out of
their misery you can put them on their
misery and then skinning them takes
about ten minutes it's almost - it's
almost - realist but it is a masterpiece
you haven't put down what you'll never
play it right well the reason being is I
played the part of the first one I and
then I was telling I was playing the
games within the games like poker and
then yeah and I I just know I know I
know me I know eight the darts yeah do
you know that I do know all of it
I know me as I will just lose myself in
now alright so but you so wait your
point of view though is is that you
don't want to play Red Dead Redemption
because you don't want to play video
games for that long but last night what
time did you play till me and Griffin
played till like like a weaned off
destiny that's the reason oh you can't
you can't if I come to your house your
point I could quit no denial no I could
quit it the reason why you won't play
red road to the river dungeon is not
because of the fact that you don't want
to be playing video games is because you
don't want it you want you don't want to
stop playing destiny
[Music]